relations avec les premiers
nation investissements du gouvernement
du québec dans bon gardien et les 20 ans
du référendum il ya plusieurs sujets qui
ont monopolisé l'attention au cours de
la dernière semaine et il y en a
d'autres qui sont pensés plutôt sous le
radar médiatique
marie-hélène québec 40 se retrouvent en
congé forcé la ministre de la sécurité
publique a été encore une fois très
occupé cette semaine en raison de la
crise à val d'or mais en plus en plus
extérieur déposé un projet de loi qui
est passée complètement inaperçue
effectivement à la fin du mois de mars
le détenu francis boucher le fils de
maurice mom boucher l'ancien chef des
hells a été libéré par erreur de la
prison de bordeaux
et cette histoire là daniel avait
beaucoup fait jaser et cette bourde en
quelque sorte un peu forcé la main de la
ministre de la sécurité publique
elle a donc déposé un projet de loi pour
forcer l'identification des détenus par
l'entremise des empreintes digitales
alors dans un premier temps le
gouvernement va consacrer 250 mille
dollars pour installer ces appareils
dans quatre centres de détention
bordeaux justement rivière des prairies
québec et saint jérôme et dans trois
palais de justice celui de montréal de
québec et de saint jérôme
après quoi il y aura une deuxième phase
deux cent cinquante mille dollars plutôt
300 mille dollars sont reconcentrés est
consacrée justement à l'installation de
ces appareils dans l'ensemble des
centres de détention mais aussi dans
tous les palais de justice du québec
alors est ce que justement ce sera
réaliste que ce projet de loi soit
adopté et entre en vigueur rapidement
parce que la ministre avait promis que
ses premiers appareils seraient
installés d'ici le mois de décembre les
vous l'avez dit daniel avec l'absence de
la ministre lise thériault pour une
période indéterminée
faudra voir c'est le ministre des
affaires municipales clairement aux qui
a pris le relais mais il faudra évaluer
justement les priorités des prochaines
semaines et lui cumule des fonctions
dans ce pourait ça pourrait rendre la
chose un peu plus
effectivement et vous justin trudeau a
annoncé cette semaine qu'ils allaient
s'installer au 24 sussex la résidence
officielle a besoin d'innovation situez
vous le temps il a plutôt choisi le bon
galop au rideau sur les terrains du
gouverneur général
ce dont on a moins tendu par l'est par
contre c'est le défi que lui a lancé un
groupe écologiste
oui et c'est la fondation sierra club
canada qui a lancé le défi à justin
trudeau de faire une rénovation
patrimoniale écologique du 24 sussex
ce qui n'est pas rien voici lui tendit
style de faire les choses correctement
il ya une opportunité de faire quelque
chose dans la rectitude écologique
ce qui n'est pas vraiment le cas
actuellement parce que faut-il le
rappeler simplement pour chauffer et
fournir l'électricité au 24 sussex à
côte en ce moment 70 mille dollars par
année donc rénover cette résidence vont
coûter très cher en 2008 la
vérificatrice générale parlait de 10
millions de dollars
ce sera bien davantage cette fois ci
alors pourquoi pas pour faire
correctement isolation fenêtres panneaux
solaires bref essayer de rendre seul le
plus écologique possible laisser une
marque qui pourrait servir d'exemple aux
canadiens mais il ya un autre son de
cloche daniel qu'on attend un célèbre
architecte canadien qui s'appelle brian
mech airlines
un homme qui a remporté des dizaines et
des dizaines de prix d'architecturé a
dit cet immeuble de 24 sussex est
absolument insignifiant détruisez le
recommencer à zéro
il a eu un appui important là dedans
maureen mcteer la conjointe de l'ex
premier ministre joe clark a dit raser
tout ça ça vaut absolument pas la peine
de rénover bref deux écoles de pensée
mais est-ce qu'un bout de ligne on fera
un immeuble écologique faudra voir voir
les trouver des panneaux solaires du
style de l'époque s'est passé c'est
effectivement prostrée merci à vous deux
bonnes semaines au revoir merci